which EU country is responsible for my
social security coverage if I get sick
who provides my benefits if I worked in
more than one country who pays my
pension when I retire considering moving
to another European Union country if you
do your social security rights and your
families will be protected
take Ana she starch living and working
in Amsterdam her Social Security rights
were covered by the Netherlands then she
met mati Oh from Rome moved to Italy and
found a job there
the Italian Social Security system now
covers Anna and this includes her health
care and fraternity benefits family
benefits unemployment benefits and her
pension rights living in and working in
Italy she has the same social security
rights as an Italian national remember
only one country is responsible for your
social security coverage at a time
usually the one where you work however
there are exceptions for example if your
employer sends you to another country on
a short assignment
or if you work in two or more countries
Ana's Italian employer sent us a Hungary
on a short assignment she is there for
less than two years and continues to
work for the Italian employer so Ana
continues to be covered in Italy this
avoids changes of legislation for
employees sent to work for short periods
abroad and are loved moving around in
Europe she always wanted to live in
Sweden and a job opportunity made it
possible she now works for a Danish
company two days a week she works in its
branch in Sweden where she also lives
for the rest of the week she works in
her company's headquarters in Denmark so
which country is now responsible for her
social security coverage because Ana
works more than 25% of her hours in
Sweden and lives there also Sweden is
responsible for her social security
coverage otherwise she would have been
insured in Denmark
it's where her employer is based in her
career Anna worked and was insured in
the Netherlands Italy and Sweden
thanks that EU rules every EU country
where she was insured will pay her an
old-age pension when she reaches the
pensionable age the amount she will
receive from each country will depend on
how long she was covered there the EU
rules on Social Security coordination
enable you to move around Europe and
protect your social security rights find
out more on the EC don't you open you
four slash Social Security coordination
[Music]